Movies with a low rating on Rotten Tomatoes
are common.
But to get a 0 percent rating takes a certain
kind of awfulness.
Sure, it's usually not the type of perfect
the filmmakers were going for, but to get
any kind of perfectly unanimous response on
a film is quite a feat.
Though watching a bad movie on purpose can
seem like a complete waste of time, some of
these just have to be seen to be believed.
Find out how things can go so wrong, so fast
with these critical bombs you should watch
anyway.
Manos: The Hands of Fate
It's one of the best episodes of Mystery Science
Theater 3000 and one of the strangest films
of all time.
From the beginning, everything about Manos:
The Hands of Fate was a bad idea.
Hal Warren told Oscar-winning screenwriter
Stirling Silliphant that making a movie was
easy.
He figured it was so simple, he bet Silliphant
that even he, a lowly fertilizer salesman,
could finish a picture.
When your grand artistic vision stems from
winning a bet, you're already off to a bad
start.
So Warren raised $19,000 from friends and
family and started filming Manos.
He crafted a complicated story about a family
that gets lost on vacation and stumbles upon
a cult leader that tries to turn all the women
in his family to his stable of bickering brides.
“You are a trouble maker.
You deserve to die!”
It could’ve been something simple, but it
wasn’t.
Manos is definitely not a cash grab.
Instead, it’s a bizarre expression of art.
Though everything about it is strange, there
did seem to be some attempt at making a real
film.
At the end of the day, Manos is a movie about
a real family coming together, giving their
all, and trying to make art no matter how
low-budget or strange.
Roller Boogie
This disco-infused roller skating wreck was
supposed to be a breakout role for Exorcist
alum Linda Blair.
If she wanted to get as far away from her
Exorcist casting as possible, the idea of
doing a harmless roller skating picture doesn't
sound like a bad idea.
Right?
“Now I can’t wait.”
Okay, maybe it was a bad idea.
Unfortunately, everyone hated the film, and
it did little to lift her career.
Roger Ebert wrote,
"I didn't think it was still possible, in
the dog-eared final days of the 1970s, to
have this silly, innocent, lame-brained and
naive movie."
The fact that the film contained all disco
music, which was fading in popularity, didn't
help matters.
Xanadu came out the next year, just to double-check
that the nation was truly over roller dancing.
Yeah … we were over it.
Heartbeeps
"I'm here to tell you about this new movie.
It’s called Heartbeeps, and it’s about
me and my pals."
Andy Kaufman and Bernadette Peters star as
two robots who were created to be human companions.
When they meet each other, they fall in love
and run away.
Which is kind of cute.
But that's not the whole story of Heartbeeps.
There's also a tank-like robot called Crimebuster
who's come to hunt them down, a garbage child
robot that Kaufman made from spare parts,
and Catskil, a corny stand-up comedian robot
who serves no purpose whatsoever.
"But believe me folks, this movie’s got
a lot goin' for it."
Though the movie is weird and a lot of the
jokes are hokey, what makes it all the more
strange is the robot design.
Peters looks like some kind of overly-oily
first-generation fembot.
Kaufman's robot could be a carbon copy of
a too-tan Chevy Chase.
Kaufman appeared in so few films, it's worth
watching Heartbeeps for that alone, and it
also serves as a warning that even the funniest
people can manage to make awfully unfunny
things.
Megaforce
Star Wars is one of the most influential films
of all time, but one of the biggest effects
of the sci-fi blockbuster was the crazy amount
of ripoffs that followed in its wake, like
the epic failure Megaforce.
Megaforce is about, you know, explosions and
laser guns.
It's hard to admit, but even after multiple
viewings, the only thing from Megaforce that
will be mega-impressed upon your brain is
Barry Bostwick's booty.
Now, that's not to say this film isn't worth
watching.
The weird mix of comedy and action plus the
utter lack of a budget make this a pretty
funny watch.
You won't get some intricate tale of space
intrigue, but you will get to see one of the
worst flying motorcycle special effects.
“I can’t understand / But I’ve only
been so far.”
Seriously, who thought that looked good?
Plus, there's the added bonus Barry Bostwick
with bleached hair looking like a rejected
Gibb brother.
As the New York Times' review of the film
put it, "The combination is original — just
as a peanut butter and olive loaf sandwich
might be — but it isn't any good."
Staying Alive
Though you may only remember Saturday Night
Fever for its disco dancing and white bell
bottoms, it's actually a really great film
about lower-class kids trying to find some
good and hope in their lives.
As the sequel to Saturday Night Fever, Staying
Alive has none of that.
In Staying Alive, Tony Manero has moved to
Manhattan and wants to be a dancer on Broadway.
Unlike the first film where Tony is a charming
but troubled young man, here Tony is just
an all-the-time jerk.
Now in addition to the Bee Gees, we get the
dulcet tones of Frank Stallone, brother of
Sylvester Stallone — who directed the film.
The dance numbers are bizarre, the leotards
are cut high, and the story is just garbage.
But it's great garbage!
MAC and Me
Another film from the ripoff department, this
D-grade E.T. has the double distinction of
trying to capitalize on Spielberg's incredibly
successful film and being a great excuse for
blatant product placement.
MAC stands for Mysterious Alien Creature,
and it turns out that Coca-Cola, not Reese's
Pieces, pleases this alien, although MAC is
way more fond of product placement than his
Spielbergian counterpart.
A whole scene is devoted to a birthday party
held at McDonald's that features Ronald McDonald
himself, and enough of the chain's logos to
fund the production company's next five knockoffs.
There's also a dance number, which ET is notably
lacking, so at least one thing was different.
“A friend in the end / Is always there / To
give their heart”
Seriously, it just goes on like that.
Another reason to see this one: Almost every
time Paul Rudd goes on Conan to promote a
film, he switches out the clip of his own
movie with the same clip of MAC and Me.
Rudd has done this for over a decade, and
for some reason it never gets old.
Simon Sez
Simply watching a Simon toy light up for an
hour and a half would contain better acting
than this Dennis Rodman sequel.
The original, entitled Double Team, featured
the bad boy basketball player and Jean-Claude
Van Damme teaming up to kick butt and give
horrible line readings.
"Their styles are different.
Very different."
For the sequel, Van Damme did not return,
so they got the next best thing: Dane Cook.
The movie has a lot of "comedy" and plenty
of Rodman looking cool while super fake explosions
happen behind him.
The film is a great reminder of a time when
Rodman was a really big deal.
1999 feels so, so far away.
Pinocchio
If you want to see the second-worst film of
all time, sit down for a terrible evening
with Pinocchio.
No, not the Disney version.
The 2002 Roberto Benigni vehicle.
After winning two Oscars for Life is Beautiful,
America was charmed by this excitable Italian
and couldn't wait for what wonderful film
he'd bring to us next.
Unfortunately, the next film he brought was
this one.
“It’s Pinocchio!”
“Pinocchio!”
It's odd enough that a 49-year-old Benigni
decided to play the small puppet child, but
the American version had to make it even weirder.
Instead of dubbing the film with Benigni's
accented voice in English, Breckin Meyer of
Road Trip fame was chosen.
The 30-something voice of Meyer coming out
of the nearly 50-year-old body of Benigni
is simply disturbing.
Plus, the fairy tale film has a good moral:
say no to a film where you play a 10-year-old
if you're pushing 50.
Ballistic: Ecks vs Sever
Now, it's true that all these films have a
0 percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes, but the
crown of worst of the worst has to go to Ballistic:
Ecks vs. Sever.
A lot of films that reach this level only
have a couple dozen reviews.
Since there are fewer critics chiming in,
the odds of a perfectly bad score are a little
better.
But Ecks vs. Sever was a major release, and
a lot of critics agreed that it deserved the
ultimate F. 116 critics, to be exact.
They all agreed this movie was garbage.
It beats the next worst movie by almost 50
critics.
Ouch.
What makes this film so hated?
Critics seem to agree that the movie has a
convoluted plot, no character development,
and a ton of messy-looking explosions that
all just blend together after a while.
Still, it's worth watching just to see what
Rotten Tomatoes considers the very worst of
them all.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!